today's episode is brought to you by
Ridge wallet Ridge wallet it's a special
type of wallet because it's different
than what you have usually some people
have a wallet it's in the back of their
pocket you know they got that bump they
got that camel bootie but now everything
can change Ridge wallet is a front
pocket carry minimize what you carry
keep it in the front
no more pick pocketers you ever been on
croatia good luck keeping your wallet
there it's a dangerous place sometimes
but with that Ridge wallet front pocket
carry you'll be okay Ridge wallet calm /
theö for 10% off let's go into this okay
I mean you know that is half way to
Christmas do you know that I can smell
some reindeers ass cheeks around yeah
you know they and some people like oh
that's gross now if you smelled a
reindeers aspera mmm like cinnamon you
know yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
we go
[Music]
right there you know that's a that's a
smoky little beat right there submitted
by Jameson flood and Jameson's been a
listener since the beginning of the
podcast thank you so much for that
hitter right there that's called no sale
and if you have some unique music you
can submit it through the through this
past weekend website and that's on Theo
von comm do this halfway to Christmas
can you believe it
so if you thinking right now saved you
thinking about Santa you know cuz I
think about saying a lot and if you're
thinking about Santa you have to you
have to understand that he is he's kind
of just I'm determining males off he's
coming yeah
waking up you know he's kind of cuz
Santa can sleep through anything you
know he got a million uh little people
you know pair somos McDaniels hammerin
and his in his in his garage you know
they're building trains they're building
walkie-talkies they're building some of
them you know did you build you know you
build a couple hundred thousand trained
you some of y'all start to Graham off
and buy a little bit of dope so you know
he he's got all kinds of stuff to deal
with you know he goes outside and you
know suddenly the place where they were
making wagons and they were you know
they were knitting dolls suddenly the
bat you know back behind that little
building people's back there they got a
little cook house and they'd you know
they grilling a brisket and and uh you
know uppers met them vitamins you know
you know I'm saying the [ __ ] and the
devil's vitamins boy you know the
methamphetamine son and so you know that
that's Santa right now he's got work to
do you know cuz he's just stretching up
a because when you do when you because
when you ride all night like Santa
nobody works as hard as Santa think
about it
you know Jesus maybe you know Muhammad
who's a little fat guy with the
jewelry on not um no I understand you
guys are thinking probably evolved
pitbull no I'm talking about the Indian
the day of the Buddha so yeah you know
his Santa's in a class of his own and
they have you know any and so when you
work that hard at once one fell swoop
you gotta you have to get that rest and
so Santa if you think about him right
now in June he's you know he just he
probably have birds living in his beard
you know and he probably has uh you know
some of his mustache probably has a
little bit of dope smoke in it cuz you
know a lot of the you know a lot of the
elves and [ __ ] like I said you know a
lot of the elves people don't realize
when you when you caught up in that elf
game it's it's like working for the
carnival it's like working for the
circus and you get in that elf game and
next thing you know y'all are you know
you got you guys are hanging out at
night and it's boring it's cold you've
been making [ __ ] Tamagotchis all day
you know we're building kick balls are
building you know softball catcher mitts
and things like that you know toys for
children you've been building all types
of things that you know sometimes kids
will get something for their parents but
the gift is a piece of [ __ ] right
because kids don't know what parents
want so they'll get them like a um like
a wooden bowl or something that's
nothing you know that's nothing or I
remember one time they had to get one of
our next-door neighbors gave his dad a
[ __ ] a huge like crate full of
scallions ditch onions and you could go
in the ditch and get free see all the
scallions you want it well this boy had
been collecting them for probably two
months and then he [ __ ] hit his dad
on Christmas with this box of uh you
know with this box of ditch onions and
next and that thing stank to high hell
man
dude it smelled like that I mean it just
smelled like a like a suppository of the
devil you know that thing smelled like
it had been hiding in the deep caves you
know men being naughty and and this boy
gave it to his daddy you know this boy
Richard that lived in our neighborhood
and and actually in orders the crazy
thing was his name was mr. Richard and
he was a kid but his dad um his dad had
his day at his grandfather had died and
the dad like missed the day you know his
dad so much and he used to call his dad
mr. Richard and so then he named his son
miss after his own dad mr. Richard so
dude this dude you got a [ __ ] you know
eleven-year-old mr. Richard you know
with that dirty box of [ __ ] ditch
onions and he hit his dad with that and
that was a you know a Christmas gift so
what I'm saying is you know you get a
lot of these people who you know you get
a lot of crazy gifts that that Santa's
elves have to make and that you know
that the the story about mr. Richard and
the money ins doesn't correlate super
well but you know what I'm saying
is that these elves have to make [ __ ]
that they don't even want to make they
got to make all the gifts that kids give
to their dad you know so no you might
give your data um you know a
roller-skate made out of cotton and your
next thing you know you're your daddy
your stepdads out there any [ __ ] you
know breaks his ankle and so it's like
but still you know who makes all of that
is elves and so these we got you know
and it becomes like the carnival you
know they're carnies dude that's how all
elves are bruh they're a bunch of Jesus
birthday carnies and so they're out
there like that and they got to build
all these wild things and so when Santa
wakes up he's got a lot of housecleaning
to do you know and this would honestly
be a crazy good time for a zip recruiter
ad wouldn't it but I don't have one
that's a [ __ ] good joke though
because imagine if Santa had that but he
doesn't so he's got to go out there and
look all these elves in the eyes and so
Santa gotta get out there and look all
these elves and their [ __ ] eyes and
some of their eyes are all glassed over
and they're all doped up and they're
hiding you know grams
you know kilograms of dope in their jaw
and all that kind of [ __ ] but when
you're an elf you could do you can
really get bent out because imagine a
couple hits I ass it'll do to a 6-footer
you you're an elf but when you are an
elf man and then you know and the ankle
bones connected to the neck bone and you
do a couple hits LSD Sun yang Yang you
go in deep you go in deep while you
Randy Moss and you feel me and so just
just know that when Santa that Santa
right now is waking up and he knows that
he still has a lot of work to do and I
think that's kind of just what I'm
thinking about right now is uh you know
it's just I got a lot of work to do we
got a lot of work to do you know if we
want if we want it you know if we want
it whatever it is if it's that family
you know if you want a new puppy if you
want to [ __ ] you know you want a new
shower curtain or a new um what does
that thing called a thing or you you
know push your clothes down and a bunch
of you know in one spot at a time but uh
iron he you know ironer iron an iron you
know if you want to you know whatever
you want you know if you want a new job
you want a new family you want the
courage to tell somebody the truth
whatever you want we still got work to
do if we want to get there but I
appreciate you guys being here with me
today and thank you jamison flood for
that intro hitter that brought us in
that as song is called no sale and
that's just a smoky little treat that
that man put together just for us oh I
was in Canada I was in Canada and man I
got look I said this on my Instagram's
if I die Lord bring me back in Canada
man it's the nicest people if you want
to know probably maybe what America was
like
fifty years ago or something in the
hearts of people like good when people's
hearts were in a good spot or you know
and maybe that's me romanticizing
America and that's fine but I think you
go to Canada I think you're gonna see a
mass exodus to Canada at some point
because dude if you want that if you
want your Canada dude look you in Canada
you could you could break your leg right
you're laying in the street someone will
come up and [ __ ] rip their own leg
off and replace your leg and you're like
what brah don't you need your leg and
the guy will be like oh you know you
know I've been I've had my leg for you
know maybe 40 years and um it's been a
good run you know you can use it and
gonna be like what the [ __ ]
so now you running around you gotta
fight your duel you know legas and ship
you got American leg and a Canadian leg
and that's how they are dude if you if
you just even look short of breath some
Canadian you know a beautiful Canadian
woman will come up and just just fill
you with that frosty friendly air of
them mountains you know that Canadian
hit you know like what was that for and
she's like oh you you just looked a
little light to me you know in the in
the O two tits you know in the lungs he
looked a little light in the lungs and
man they're just so friendly did are
they got a little windy I was walking on
the street selling my hair blue over my
eyes bro someone immediately came and
moved it off of my eyes
that's Canada just kind people man I
mean and it's like and here like an
America kindness is something that we
have to push you know I mean I think
about it a lot you know like how do I
stay out of myself and think about
others and a man in candidates not like
that I can't even explain it to you I
can't even explain it to you and you
would think because they're so cold you
know they're frosty you know if you look
at go find a picture of a Canadian if
you look in the background of that
picture there some does
huge piece of land back there with ice
on it you know I mean it's God's freeze
her brother that's that frozen food
section you know I'm saying they got all
you you walk far enough in Canada you
[ __ ] it's just like you know it's
just a bunch of toasty nose and a bunch
of frozen pizzas and you know they got
all kind of frozen meats and ice trays
everything it's the frozen food universe
up there you know and I didn't think
Canada was real when I was growing up
they didn't even I remember when I was
in middle school and do we have some
characters middle school we had this one
dude speaking of mr. Richard earlier we
had this boy in our middle school named
uh actually the mr. Larry and he was
probably he might have been 21 and this
is back when you stayed in middle school
- you got it you know I'm saying they
wasn't just pushing everybody through
like now you know now if you got half
the alphabet you can [ __ ] finish you
know 10th grade but this is back in the
day they have this do mr. Larry you know
kind of a little bit of a darker skin
than me kind of and he ah dude this guy
was 20 maybe 18 in middle school biggest
Nicky I ever seen and for most kids I'm
sure it was the first real you know real
local meet that they ever saw unless
they you know unless their dog brought
home a ferret and left it on their front
door one day and they opened the door to
go to school and it was a big long
ferret right there with a little bit of
you know teeth marks in it but damn mr.
Larry bro he had this sweat he had a
straight-up [ __ ] on him and he dude he
would when you were urinating in the
restroom he would pee over you into the
urinal and make it in every time bro I
mean this dude was the [ __ ] I mean
this dude was just the Steph Curry of
piss and uh and eventually they just
made him a janitor he never finished all
the grades or whatever you know he never
got through sixth grade and they made
him a damn janitor and he was you know
he was there for years I don't know if
he's still there if he's even still
alive he didn't seem like the kind of
person I was probably gonna live very
long you know because he didn't
sometimes you can just look somebody in
the eyes and be like okay this is you
know limited-edition and he kind of had
that vibe oh but I was I talking about
being a kid middle school I was talking
about Oh Canada man what was I talking
about
being young urinating and then someone
oh I talked about man what was I talking
about
man I can't think of it right now and
now I'm just starting to feel suddenly
disappointed in myself
you know and I know I shouldn't be cuz
this is just this isn't a bad thing
there's just part of life you know and
sometimes your brain when you really
think about the size of your brain it's
amazing that it holds what it does isn't
it
dude your brain is as big as like a
[ __ ] you know like a quart of rocky
road weight or maybe half quart think
about that your brain is as big as a
half a quart of ice cream and you have
everything in there everything think of
something if you did just think of
something then you did it with your
[ __ ] brain you nut sack so that's
reverse mind ecology boy just got you on
that one
yeah whatever you just thought of you
thought about with your brain so
therefore it came right out of your
brain but damn I wish my brain had
everything in it because it doesn't have
whatever I was trying to remember from a
few minutes ago what I was talking about
what are we talking about you got to get
your I was talking about getting going I
was talking about we still got work to
do
I was talking about growing up I was
talking about being in school and going
back to school and damn dude I'm not
of it I gotta think of it we talked
about Santa and there's still work to do
we talked about what else doing
something we talked about Santa there's
still work to do we talked about being
in Canada people are so nice they blow
the air right into your lungs you know
they're just that kind of people and
well I think I you know I think I just
Canada you know I know we're talking
about Canada and no matter what tangent
I was on I'm gonna start back there
because you know I just had a great time
man and it's a beautiful place and
people are just so friendly I mean
they're friendly at a level like here I
feel like we have to we have to remind
ourselves this what I was talking about
I think to remember to be friendly you
know it's almost like we got to put a
post-it note on our shoulder and you
look down it says um you know be
friendly but there's just in their
nature dududuu would run up to you at
night in the middle of a night you're
walking on the street a dude runs up
with a knife bro and he just gives you
the knife and he's like oh you found
this beautiful knife a couple blocks
away and you know I don't want you being
out here with by yourself with no knife
you know just in case an American comes
out here and stabs you but man it was a
great dude it was just and so many
people came out we sold out all the
shows in Calgary and not a lot of women
in that city I think I saw no joke dude
nine women and probably 791 dudes but a
beautiful gang of humans came through
and I appreciate that man and nice
people nice people man and they came out
and they saw that fighter in the kids
strap I brought the belt out there with
me I brought that first place in a lot
of these clowns they wanted you know
DeLeo he's on on Twitter yesterday
asking about the strap you know Rapoport
you know that you know that wild senior
citizen he's out there you know he's
thinking about it you know he probably
looks around his mansion or whatever he
lives in you know and uh and he probably
got fancy jewelry but he ain't got Ellis
rap you know so but I had a great time
in Canada man I want to thank everybody
for coming out great time at Yuk Yuk's
and and this week and actually be a
temblor
Brewing Company and that's in
Bakersfield him we have a second show
June 29th I'll be at Paramount Theater
in Stark County Illinois two shows
that's on Friday July 6th through the
8th I'll be in Oxnard at levity live and
now I'm just gonna list cities Raleigh
North Carolina after that Laugh Factory
Chicago Nashville Tennessee Toronto Just
for Laughs festival if you have a friend
in Toronto send them to the Just for
Laughs get the website I'm there from
September 20th to 24th have them get
them tickets get them yet Asst in
Cameron and they have to like buy a
ticket and then pick who they want to
come see so I promise you done will put
on a good show man I'm so looking
forward to it after that we got buffalo
Appleton Wisconsin Salt Lake City and
Washington DC all of those are on sale
at theof on comm slash tour and I just
want to thank again the people in Canada
man I can't dude it's kind of wild
because I've you know I've been doing
this for 15 years man you know and you
go to cities and you're like you know
and nobody [ __ ] cares you know and
that's the crazy thing about this
business and you go to these places and
nobody gives a [ __ ]
and it's just you with this like heavy
like sometimes I don't know if what I
was carrying around was like a dream or
like a chip on my shoulder bra that just
hadn't really formed itself yet into
like a a dream or a burden if that makes
any sense you know so I just had this
weight on me and sometimes I would go
and do it mean I was a kind of an angry
- angry or comedian man when I started
out and I was just angry and one of the
blessings of life if you're able to live
long or long enough is that you get to
you know you people come along and they
help you shed those skins man those
heavy skins do the skins of anger and
the skins of just rage and all that [ __ ]
it gets those it get heavy and if you
get to be a lot of long and if you shed
those and this and I love that and
that's one of the blessings of being
alive for a while but
but um [ __ ] I can't remember what I'm
talking about again um and about to just
I'm about to take my own dick off and
just saying feed it to a bird that's
what I feel like right now but man I had
I just had a great time up there you
know I guess I'll have to go back to
Canada way back to Canada I just had a
great time out there and it was just oh
oh that's what I want to say thank you
just thank you for getting the ticket
thing coming out it's so different when
you go to a place and people are there
to see you as opposed to people just
being there not knowing who the [ __ ] or
what's going on it just makes me feel
like a part of something and that just
man it just feels good but yeah I didn't
know for years I didn't know and I never
really thought about it before but I
didn't know if I was carrying you know a
dream or my goals or anger sometimes or
whatever it was you know sometimes you
don't know what that weight is on you
you know it's still forming and it forms
based on people you interact with and
the things you learn and the things you
open yourself up to that's what I find
and sometimes that way can get heavier
so now I can get light and they can just
sit right if you can get so light that
it can just sit right up in front of you
you know just like it's like and then
then I think if that's when it's like a
dream it's an ambition it's it's
something that's coming to fruition you
know and that's kind of something that
I'm feeling right now it's crazy like
you know and I'm not trying to say this
from a place of ego or anything but but
gratitude I just feel man it just means
so much you know you see people come out
they had them you know we had a couple
come out and they're about to have a
child about to have their first child
you notice do Georgie I think his name
was and look in Canada bro you'll get
some names that you're like oh that's a
child's name in America you know Georgie
PD you know buzzer I'm gonna do name
buzzer like damn brother that's uh
that's like a nickname for like a kid
who you know maybe has a little bit of
cute epilepsy but but you met you know
people were just I don't know
you know we had they had a guy come on
had the biggest hand I've ever seen he's
like hey man I'm wanted to come
you got the biggest hand I got the
biggest [ __ ] hand here and he's like
hold my hand I'm my god dude on you know
and he's like no no don't hold it like a
you know like he's shaking it just hold
it just hold my hand with both of your
hands and so this whole mr. Buckenham
bruh and this dude has straight-up hand
tis immed oh this dude had you know
hands you know down hand drunk this dude
had this [ __ ] straight up I mean this
like a damn cup just a gallon of just
just a gallon of straight [ __ ] icy
beef at the end of his wrist and who
else came out man that was wild you know
I saw a pair of brothers came out you
know a guy and his younger brother and
that always means the world to me that
her father son came out and and the son
said this was my dad's Father's Day gift
and that meant the world you know like
just because then I get to be a part of
like whatever you're a part of you know
like I don't I can't explain it I just
you know and when I get to be a part of
whatever like your you know like I try
and stay after the show and say hey to
everybody and I brought the strap and
people took pictures and but I you know
I just want a little piece of I just
want to let you know like I just I I
like it makes me feel a part of when I
just get little pieces of your life you
know and you get a little piece of my
life and it's like we just it's just
this interaction manages I don't know it
just makes me feel like a part of it
makes me feel accepted I guess in some
ways and it makes me feel like I'm able
to at the same time you know learn to be
accepting and and just just not be
afraid to just be just to be I don't
know I'm rambling man I'm a ramblin man
today's episode I will say is brought to
you by grey block pizza grey block pizza
also bronx-born pizza up there in Bend
Oregon if you're up there in Bend Oregon
go to go buy bronx-born
and tell them you're a fan of this past
weekend and tell them you want to get
that hitter we also got to get that hit
our t-shirts available now after just
constant demand and you can get those
theof on.com slash store
also this episode brought to you by her
Poehler if you got herpes go to her
polar th ER PA le rt.com perp alert get
it checked out through through your
phone through the computer send the
pictures doctor somewhere herpes
hmm Hickey maybe maybe somebody that got
[ __ ] you know fell asleep outside and
got hit by a bunch of hail in the neck
or in the kak or whatever the jet you
know could be any of those things but
her polar comm you can get a checked out
know right now what's going on with you
as well some of you see my shirt that
I'm wearing this t-shirt and this shirt
says defy adversity and this is a new
clothing brand and it's called you can
and you can as a brand that's focused on
inspiring people to defy adversity
anyone who has been told that they can't
cam out because you can bruh anyone is
overcoming an obstacle or whatever you
know maybe you were born without a head
or you can't you know you never could
read or something you grew up in a town
meeting that many books and people were
burning you know pages and letters and
vowel sounds on the edge of town and
consonants and just beaten consonants up
and leaving them bloody in the street
but now you decided to get out of that
town and go to a town where there's
letters and words and everything and now
you just straight up just
supercalifragilistic gigs be out of
notion you know you live in life fully
fully fully fully fully stocked with
letters and sounds and words and
everything and that's that's you can as
you defying adversity and so and you can
check out their stuff and you can get a
15% discount and that is defy adversity
calm and vo n is the code for 15% off
defy adversity calm and you someone got
to defy the dark arts you know because
they're out there so so you just go
check them out and if you like it then
get that hitter we'll put the link right
here below we had so many great calls
that came in on the hotline I can't wait
to share with you I just want to let you
guys know some of the stuff we had a lot
of response calls for you know that bad
boy out there with them breasts I think
it was your boy Joe called in and he had
them straight up front you know them you
know them nippled up them straight up
[ __ ] man
and he was hitting the beach and stuff
and he had different types of feelings
about that so we got some responses for
him
we have a live raised fan line now we'll
have a link where you can go and you can
leave a 15-second video to be an ask a
question and we'll put it into the
YouTube segment we're going to launch
some of those today some of you guys
have already left them and that link
will be in the YouTube comments as well
and in the iTunes comments that link
where you can go there live raise it's
free it is free to leave a video
question 15 seconds and ask ask us a
question and we'll put your video
directly into the show if it fits but
let's get into some calls I like to know
who's listening to this past weekend and
and this is someone right here here we
go the oh bomb their game gang buddy it
is noted man Nelson down in Texas and
they had a Nelson they had to do named
Nelson bus that got bit by a crab one
time at the beach do that Steve fell
asleep on spring break and a huge crab
bit him in the UM in the neck or
something that dude he'd never been the
same dude he ended up doing all kinds of
illegal [ __ ] he was teaching student
driving and then stole a bunch of the
cars and sold them across state lines a
bunch of dumb [ __ ] but anyhow thanks for
calling Nelson onward man's working for
the Postal Service I'm actually sitting
in my mail truck right now
I'm sorry going right now it's hot right
now hundred twelve damn 112 degrees
Nelson and you got there hanging out
with mail bro you up there just sitting
in a truck sweating on some mail wow
that's almost I mean that's crazy dude
that's kind of your rhotic even just
picturing a man out there dis all sweaty
hands just touching all that mail it
sound like you would just what about all
those like um I would wonder if all the
stamp glue starts to you know seep out
of those crevices of the letters and
just get all over your skin and
everything let's hear more hot Nelson in
the truck I just want a semi-infinite
show so listen to you
all back sometimes you were on fire in
the kid you're a funny dudes man beep
thank you thanks Nelson I appreciate
that man and I you know and I um I
always loved the postal system dude you
know I'm saying sometimes the postal
system you know that could be you know
like when I was young you had to use
that thing I'm saying you wanted to tell
somebody who cared bro you better [ __ ]
in you had to write it down put it it
take one piece of paper folds up put it
into another piece of paper get a
special secret little thing stamp lick
it get a lick the back of it dude
already this sounds like something you
know this sounds like a way you're gonna
end up high or something then you had to
put the thing you licked on to the other
thing right then you had to write
exactly where we're supposed to go on
the front then you had to go put it in a
box out in your front yard
if this doesn't sound like a [ __ ]
script for Narnia I can't even tell you
what does then a man you didn't even
know who gets bit by dogs and animals
all the time had to come and pick it up
and take it away and every now and then
you would hear that one of those men
went insane and shot up his work
facility and that was mail so I respect
so much Nelson you out there you know
you out there still riding the rails you
know cuz mail is it's really man it's
the Greyhound bus of communication dude
anything can happen
dude when I lived in Tucson Arizona I
still live in Tucson Arizona I used to
was a busboy out there for a long time
at a place called City grill one of my
favorite I mean I loved that job so much
man I loved being a busboy you know dude
you were just [ __ ] slinging around
and people were doing dope and you know
the guy who worked the oven would always
be falling asleep and you wake that dude
up before he [ __ ] burned himself but
they had a postman buddy this dude he
was on something you know he was gang
ganging up in his wrist or something or
just hiding you know grams of cocaine up
in the up in his nose and he would come
by like three nights a week dude
midnight 11 p.m. throw all the [ __ ]
mail
into the front your heart brah just BAM
dude this dude was just like just making
it rain bills and coupons and and just
different ship via the mail list it
would just [ __ ] it bruh get your [ __ ]
and cruise mail truck unmarked he would
spray-paint another [ __ ] on the side of
it dude straight up just straight up a
straight up real just human vulture man
so I know you guys are living wild out
there Nelson I appreciate you riding the
rails brother dark I mean that's the
dark arts that's the dark arts of
delivery communication right there when
you're out there still you know you're
working that mail and you're fending off
animals basically you're somebody has to
fight animals so you can get like
perfume samples and coupons and grand
parental a lot of grandparents still use
that mail system
and that means so much that when you get
that letter from one even when your
loved ones you know I get a lot of
people to Midwest so you know a
Midwestern grandmother she'll [ __ ]
write you for no reason
she'll write you man and she'll just and
that that let her feel so warm and just
toasty and breasty and you read that
thing and it smells like cookies and
feelings and man you do that for people
you delivering those hitters Nelson so
thank you for calling and thanks for
listening to this past week and I'd love
to know who's out there who's out there
and who's ears are am i helping babysit
for a little bit of time on on a monday
halfway to Christmas David and look at
all these gifts we get Nelson out there
one of those freelance elves baby
Goering yeah we had we had some good
calls that came in last week do you know
the boy called in about them teats bruh
and he sent me a mail as well and his
name is Jeff he said this is the email
and they don't play the calls for you
guys he said hey Theo I'm Jeff toy I'm
the guy with the call about the man
boobs on your bald is beautiful episode
I appreciate you taking my call man and
I appreciate you calling your story
about your friend was awesome dang but
you must be packing if you're passing
out from your boners
well I mean look bro I come in thick
right there
you know I come in thick and the key and
um and it's not fun passing out from
erections bro cuz you know I'm saying
you can't you can't if you you know I'm
saying you can't [ __ ] if you faint
that's really now if you can ride that
just ride that dark kind of line of just
right between the barely conscious and
still erect then you can really make
love and you can do well out there in
them of a Jeets you know then vagine
streets but but that's such a rap minute
so hard to do that it's so hard to walk
that line because otherwise and you have
to you know you just said you you just a
risky Triscuit you know you're a
dangerous cracker because you are you
you know just a little too much blood of
the bone and you're out but anyhow and I
mean interrupt you this is the more of
Jeff saw email I used to give away free
grabs for my cousin's that never touched
a teddy before and that's awesome dude
that's cool man for shock value at
parties I used to lick my nipples that's
that's fun that's fun - that's fun
that's not like something that like
people do like in Norway or something
where it's you know they don't have a
lot of different types of games and
stuff at their house if I wanted to
transition to the ladies side I would be
halfway there you know and that's pretty
beautiful Brooke because you never know
you never know if we cracked you open
with an axe they might have two or three
beautiful women inside of you you never
know what's inside of you thanks for
making me laugh that's all we can do for
now anyways keep on keep on keeping on
see you in Nashville playboy so there
you go big Jeff with them [ __ ] front
baby sacks is gonna come out to
Nashville and I'm excited to see you out
there Jeff and that's a zany's huh and
that's in I think November September but
let's play some calls some calls came in
for responses for you I'm a lot of
people really cared about this about you
know what it's like to be a man and have
you know I'm just gonna say tits bro you
know cuz you know that's what it is and
let's go on
okay here we go
I was going on Theo this is Jonathan
from Shreveport
down in Louisiana hey Jonathan thank you
for calling down there in Shreveport and
uh a lot of our listeners know that Andy
Dick who is an entertainer and a
miscreant tried to give me a [ __ ] in
Shreveport one time and I denied him and
then three years later I was in the
street for it again and he tried to give
me a [ __ ] didn't remember he'd
offered me three years previously and I
denied him as well again then for
multiple reasons you know I've never had
a man you know within mouth distance I'm
a dick and um and also just I mean in
you know I don't date men essentially or
anything I mean I'll you know I'll sit
next to a guy in a movie you know and
I'll even maybe sit in between two guys
if the place is full but um and I'm you
know I could make love to a man when I'm
70 or 80 who knows and I'm saying that's
far off but for now you know I want to
have a wife and children and everything
but um but anyhow what I want oh and
then also in in uh in Shreveport I ended
up at a after-hours with John Legend and
and he was just playing music in this
little bitty I mean it was like nine
people in this room and he's in there
playing music on a beautiful piano let's
hear more thank you for calling Jonathan
uh was just watching the podcast and
seen a guy call in talking about being
overweight and all that and I know a
little bit about what he's talking about
because I was like that when I was
younger as far as the manboobs situation
goes he should really think about doing
a lot of chest exercises and stuff like
that
to kind of you know work on are you
talking about tightening up them Tetons
huh
you bout you don't say any time you you
you brought your trying to tighten up
them little for the little nerve them
little
them little nerve nodules that he's got
them T toss yeah I guess if you could do
enough bench presses to [ __ ] get them
tits strong then that maybe that's
realistic armored bringing the DS down
to eighth if you know what I mean there
is people out there that rooting for man
just let them know that you got it bud I
just let him know and you just let him
know so thank you for that call yeah if
you were rooting for you you know you're
not alone if we all if all of us could
just get up right next to your chest
Geoffrey and just put out one finger and
just push that tit back into your soul
you know and then just as a group and
this another group comes along with
other people that care about you you
know these tits that you don't fully you
know really want around your body or
part of you and just push that thing
back into the Oblivion back into the
abyss of creation so it just molds back
but you know you there are a lot of
people supporting you and you don't know
Geoffrey you don't know if one day you
might get these tits chopped off you
know and no I know that probably just
made a lot of our female listeners
squeal and I'm sorry about that I didn't
mean that you know but if you didn't if
you got these breasts artfully detached
then you might be able to mold that into
something for somebody else you know you
might be able to make a little nut sack
for somebody out of some of that skin or
fat you might be able to make a nut sack
for somebody in you know in Guam or in
um you know Evansville Indiana or you
know somebody that's you know stuck
somewhere trapped in the mountains or
somebody that's starving you can make a
you know you could make maybe a little
candy for a cannibal out of that extra
breast meat that's you know if you got
your breasts removed so you just don't
know what can happen but thank you for
that call that came in let's hear
another one here we go
hey this is Renee from New York and I'm
just calling in to give a quick comment
on the previous caller talking about his
pair of man cities mmm-hmm thank you for
calling Renee homeward and has struggled
with that and me being the proud owner
of a pair of man cities I very much
identified with that just wanted to say
that man this world will convince you
that whatever it is that you're bringing
to the table in
yeah that's a great statement I
appreciate you saying that you know it
is I don't you know I wonder if it's or
if it's this world or if it's us you
know or if it's a mix but yeah there's a
dirty recipe out there that leaves us
feeling like whatever we're bringing to
the table isn't good enough you know and
I think it all the time but my you know
I got limited neck I got that limited
neck man and I just put my little cousin
David on Instagram he got that specialty
Reacher you know he got that real reach
or bruh that dude probably running on
four or five extra vertebrates you know
they're outside above his clavicles so
he got those you know those those a see
above clavicle those a CBS as above
clavicle vertebrates and he's got that
real reach her neck so our family you
know has different type of range when it
comes to necks but yeah we've all got
something man when I was kid I had but
you know my teeth was buck and separated
I got a big nose now big ears you know
big kick you know they can sticking a
stick you know you know I got that
fainter [ __ ] you know we've all got
something you're right and somehow we
will feel less than and it's a it's
something in our society and different
elements of our society that make us
feel that way let's hear more Renee
thanks for calling and all these inside
ugly people are going to try and tell
you that with your [ __ ] ain't worth it
and the only thing that got me over my
insecurities about my man cities is
understanding that ain't nobody better
than me and I am better than nobody else
and you know the only wow so think about
that nobody's better than me and I ain't
better than anybody else dude that's
powerful that's a powerful place right
there that's a powerful place man
nobody's better than me and I ain't
better than anybody else because then
you living right there you right there
in the cockpit of comfort if you can
stay right there
it's a nice thought man it's a beautiful
thought for the day let's hear more
Renee wait so really get past it as it
is to embrace it fully so you know just
stand with a straight back and let the
world love you for who you are and if
they can't do that
they're not worth gang
defy adversity that's you know it says
it on this church today so I'm glad we
got them helping a sponsor this episode
you know it's uh it's wild it's wild how
we battle so many little things and you
know what's crazy
renee is that will will defeat the thing
or will feel good about it and then
it'll it'll come back it'll come back
and it will come back sometimes like if
something else happens then that that
previous thing you know a girl breaks up
with you don't get a job you fall down a
flight of stairs you know somebody cuts
your hair off at the library and burns
part of your hair off something happens
to you and then you feel and then this
other thing comes in immediately like a
duck a dirty bird that lands on your
shoulder you're like oh oh yeah also I
have a you know I got a big nose or also
I got you know eyes like um you know
like one of the you know like one of the
UM like kyle korver if he [ __ ] was a
hippie you know or you know you have you
have all the or I'm not tall enough I'm
not straight you know I'm not I'm not um
have a good enough posture I don't have
you know my kneecaps don't both point
forward or something all of a sudden
these other dirty birds land on your
shoulder right when something else
happens you know something else kind of
starts to push you over the edge and
then all this other just that that load
comes on to you you know that weight
just all just hammers right back on you
these things you beaten previously
they're back and that's one of those
moments where you got to figure out this
is how one oh this is one of the things
I'm learning how we how we how we can
better win in this game of life and and
stay in a comfortable spot is to fought
to notice when something bad happens
notice before that other bet other [ __ ]
comes on that's just waiting for it to
remind us that of our self-worth of just
this are all these other little nitpick
things before they come on it's a
separate to find space in there and say
okay this bad thing happened whatever
this is you know lost my job
girlfriend left me lost my arm you know
was in a fire or something can't find
you know our cats or it could be
anything but then to suddenly be like
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
handle this I'm gonna accept this I'm
gonna deal with this and I'm not gonna
let this other [ __ ] just pile on me
right now it's interesting and and
that's why and that's I must hand up
mastered I don't know anything I'm just
but I am saying in my life I'm starting
to notice in that space in there and be
able to say okay this I'm standing up to
this right now I'm recognizing it and
I'm not letting this other [ __ ] come in
right now because it's happened so many
times before and I know it just makes me
feel just twenty times as bad and then
I'll do stab at you know I'll make poor
choice and do other stuff so I stop it
now I say okay this this I got this and
you this [ __ ] y'all stay right there
because I dealt with y'all last week
let's hear one more call that came in
here for for you let's go yo Co this is
Rio the mechanic
what's up Rio thank you for calling man
in Rio means River so you that River
mechanic dude you out there [ __ ] uh
you up there hot wiring them waves you
know you out there just putting high
beams on them streams baby let's hear it
about the guy that said yes man tips I
can help out with a situation I've had
mantas before in my lifetime man that's
crazy I didn't know this was such a
popular thing for men you know I will
say that I went you know I went heavy in
a soy and I used to you know when I was
young I used you know
performance-enhancing drugs at the
school you know and I wouldn't even
[ __ ] playing a sport dude I was just
[ __ ] you know I was just doing tests
200 is to eat some lunch you know I was
just all win straw it up at the [ __ ]
recess but um but that left me feeling
kind of a little you know titta SH in in
the front spots let's hear more I'm 24
and like that guy you're 24 dude you
sound like you are well if you're 24
you're doing a great impersonation of a
44 year old right now man you sound like
a grown man
so if you do have tits I bet them
[ __ ] are hard as [ __ ] and I bet them
[ __ ] clock in and work every day and
drink Folgers because you sound like you
got to sound like a real man Rio
homeward I gained a bunch of weight when
I was a kid and that'll give you some
titties you got to deal with I tell you
what though what get flatness of tits
out now I don't know this guy's been
exercising now but what he needs to do
is do some push-ups do at least a
hundred a day try to get 25 in each set
I'm doing 150 a day and uh I've been
doing it for a month and I even hardly
got no tits anymore I don't know what
happened to them but they go on man
let's do them push-ups they're young
well Lane look man if you you pushing
them titties away and maybe that's the
thing so let me just got to push them
titties right away from your own body
but I like that I like these are some
neat options man you know come to terms
with it try some Fitness you know accept
it embrace them and that's uh you know
there's some great responses man those
are cool stuff and I'm glad that I
appreciate the calls you can always hit
the hotline if you have any thoughts
suggestions if you had an experience
with this podcast nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three is the
hotline now that's a voicemail hotline
okay yeah we get a lot of calls myself
and both of the the producers now Nick
and Chris are listening to the calls and
we're going through and you know trying
to figure out what fits best for the
episode I'll tell you this half of the
calls that come in the audio people are
on their speakerphone people are um you
know it's a bad connection
half of them we can't at barely even
hear so right now right there you down
50% so a lot of people if you've called
and it didn't get on or this or that or
sometimes you know that could be one of
the reasons why as well
man we can't make this episode a million
years long and I think dude no joke I
mean that you know I bet last this past
week robably got foreigner calls and
we're grateful for it you know and we're
and it's helping and and I guess I sound
like I'm complaining but thank you I'm
just saying oh and try to leave make it
a min
minute-and-a-half your voicemail max or
or less you know and also you can get to
the fan line now so we got those fan
line video questions and you know what
we'll go to some of those right now
we'll go to some of those right now and
these are via the link below and this is
our live raise and you can get their app
and submit a free this is free a video
question that we can put right into the
episode so here is our first one here we
go
hey Theo you've had so many celebrity
guests on this past weekend this year
who's been your favorite so far
and who do you look forward to the most
celebrity or non celebrity to be a guest
in the future thank you very much for
calling young lady we haven't had we've
only had a most six guests on this past
weekend so we haven't really had a ton
of guests but we have had we have had
some and you know I'd love to honestly
have busi badass and busi is a little
busi and he's a rapper out of uh you
know he came out of Baton Rouge and and
man I just I follow him on Instagram he
went to prison and he um and he you know
what he was in prison for a long time I
remember he was getting out of prison
and he and I remember he tweet had come
off of his Twitter account and I was
like and his Twitter kind of been it had
never been anything because he'd been
incarcerated whenever Twitter even came
out so I'm like damn dude there would
just have just been one it was a
favorite or something so I was like wow
I wonder a lot are people even thinking
about reaching out to busi yet through
Twitter and so I remember I sent a
message and it was Easter Easter was
coming up and I remember I sent busi a
message and I was like man Easter
Easter's come early
Easter's coming early the King has
returned because he was getting out of
prison like two days before Easter
something or a week before Easter and
then broke no joke like 48 hours later
something
he puts a tweet out and the tweet was
like he has you know
Easter's come he has risen or something
he's come early or something like that
just something that was very similar to
what I had sent him and in my mind you
know
you know how humans are with their egos
I'm thinking oh he got that you know I
put it in his head he got it from me and
I have no clue if that ever if that's
really how it happened or not but I love
little Bootsy man I love the way that he
works so hard if you watch him on
Instagram his work that his work ethic
is amazing and I'm out of Louisiana you
know and and I think he has you know he
has all of his children he's always
putting his children on instagrams and
any luck you can just tell that he loves
him and he loves to laugh and and I just
think he's a great role model he's a
great role model for you know probably
growing up in a lot of poverty you know
and I respect any any role model out of
poverty man whether I don't care a black
white handicap straight gay lesbian you
know whatever French anything I don't
care I can relate to that I can relate
to that person and and I can't rap I
don't have bars like busi but I can
really I just I don't know I just love
the way that he you could tell what he
cares about he works hard
you know he's always counting his money
he's if his Instagram is redic it's
funny it's ridiculous but he has fun you
know he goes to the park and he does the
other day he was giving money out to
kids he has given 40 dollars a piece I
think it was two kids that had a
straight-a report card
man that's amazing that's amazing
you know just a man and I just love it
and you can tell it's genuine it comes
from a real place in him so anyway my
dream guest for to have on this past
weekend would be a boozy badass outside
of that you know just having Chris
D'Elia was it was amazing I'd love to
have Diaz Rogen you know I'd love to
have a lot of the heroes and you know
Brendan Schaub and we're gonna get some
of these guys Brian
allons we're gonna get some of them
Nikki Glaser I really love me these are
all comedians but I want to get some
thinkers too I want to get a little bit
of everybody but thank you for calling
that's a good question that's through
the live Ray's fan line and you can see
the who who asked the question on video
if you're watching on bit on YouTube
here we go next one what's going on Theo
this is my first time doing this I'm a
little nervous
also a little oinked as well I'm also
wearing jean shorts well if you can see
this on youtube visitors laying in bed
so he's nervous he's stoned he's got on
jean shorts they're you sound boy you
hooked Phantom by yourself
ruff you bout to break out that you know
that bad boy Big Jim and just you know
and go downriver on yourself it sounds
like man he lay in a bed there that
wasn't a question but I appreciate you
hitting the live Ray's fan line right
there let's go to one more here good I
think I it's a big fan from Australia
hit man just cruising around with my dog
oh wow that's a beautiful dog man that
looks like a um what kind of dog is that
a Maltese or something maybe a
Rottweiler
oh we're just wondering if you had any
pets growing up hit up cowboy pace man
thanks for calling man that's awesome
didn't have any pets growing up dude I
got attacked by a couple cats on my
birthday once I was my first big
experience you know I went running out
of our apartment complex and I was fired
up and my mother was taking us down to
the river you know down to the river to
do you know a little bit of swimming and
just being out there and you know it in
the banks of the rivers in Louisiana
they have this red clay and it's a
strong oranjee red clay and and and when
you can dig a bunch of it up as a kid
you can squeeze it in your hands and you
just I mean you feel like you feel like
a construction worker you feel like one
of Santa's little elves you know you
like you can just you can make a whole
new universe right there in your hands
and then dip it in the water and and it
would just exist you know you just you
feel so capable
with that clay in your hands and and my
mother would take us down there and we
would have a nice time one day on my
birthday were going when I come running
out of our apartment and they had two
cats that had been on the roof you know
danger
I guess danger cats you know and these
[ __ ] came off man they came off
and got me and I didn't know they did it
like that man and they [ __ ] jump me
really so that was [ __ ] up I thought
but you know that was in the early
experience I never even saw a pet dude
tall probably 12 years old you know you
know I didn't see a pet - I was 12 I
remember being at my buddy's house in
had a dog indoors and like what in the
[ __ ] is going on you know I thought it
was like a sheep like a yellow sheep you
know there was maybe like a lesbian but
it was a golden retriever and I'm like
wow this is and it was an indoor dog
because my neighborhood they just had
loose dogs had three or four loose dogs
and if you went by them they's gonna
[ __ ] yet you know if you went by him do
that though you'll you know you're gonna
leave but probably only half your rib
cage and that was nature and that was
natural so you know it is what it is man
but that was my experience with animals
growing up and so me be getting more
comfortable around animals has been a
lifelong process you know I mean I
couldn't if somebody has cats I can't
even really be around those cats and
just recently you know been spending
time with a lady
and and I can go over and she have cats
and I can be around these cats and not
be afraid because you know suddenly it
all flashes back from me you know and
I'm blowing out candles and they got a
couple of [ __ ] felines trying to take
daddy down you know on his birthday but
after that man I got an e no I mean I
grew up in a hamster breeding area
people were selling HAMP's G pigs by me
so all of that you know we had a bunch
of animals in our lives after that but
that was my first experience the animals
but thank you for calling with that man
out of Australia good a man onward one
more fan line you know Theo I decided
recent podcast with Christopher Lee and
I'm actually kind of curious now do you
think you and him might do a
collaborative paka
oh that's a good question when we do a
collaborative podcast man you know I'll
tell you this about about Chris D'Elia
he is a you know I was intimidating I
don't fit in I don't know if it's always
been some intimidation but also I had MA
I've always admired Chris you know he
has a level of he has a level of
comfortable confidence that I there's
times early when I didn't think it was
genuine I believe that it's genuine and
it is um man I [ __ ] to it if he died
for us say if he died in front of me and
I do not wish that upon him at all you
know I think he is a tornado of talent
I mean immense talent brought that who
knows what [ __ ] talents could be
inside of that dude that he hadn't even
[ __ ] showed people yet he he might
know where gold is I mean he could be a
damn treasure hunter and he's just
saving that for when he's in his sixties
you know he may just have you know he me
you know but he has he just has that
confidence and if he ever died or
something I would do - honestly I'd take
a knife out cut a hole right in his arm
and drink some of us straight up blood
out brah I would straight-up drink some
of that dude's blood because I would
just just have that [ __ ] just to [ __ ]
feel would it just to have that taste in
my mouth of that confidence you know he
has a level of confidence that's just
staggering
and it's admirable and it's it's I don't
see it that much but then he also like
he was in here and you know he loves to
laugh man and he just loves to laugh and
now a lot when I see it when I hear him
say that and I look at his life and I
look at like the moments I see him it
that's what he just loves to do you know
he likes you know coffee and you know I
know he's always dated beautiful many
likes beautiful women he likes laughter
and he is okay with that and that's
where he is and it's you know it's
almost and look I don't feel like I'm
judging him here you know I look up to
him you know I really do look up to him
I think he's I think he's very funny and
I think he's got a big he's uh he's got
a big heart he's you know he's um he's
kind of like the Tom Cruise of affection
a little bit in some ways you know like
he's or he's not Tom Cruise but even
more like he's you know he's like the
he's like the James Bond of affection
you know he's like um you know like me
I'm mighty mo Nemo you know I'm not here
swimming in my feelings and [ __ ] but
he's uh he is more he just he doesn't
lead with that it's right there but he
doesn't lead but that um you know but he
has it you know he does a lot of nice
things that I think other people don't
even see they don't people don't see him
do but yeah he's just so confident man
it's admirable and he's just he's so
talented but yeah would we do a podcast
together I mean I think that's something
I mean it would be crazy I think because
we're so different you know we are so
different and maybe that's where some of
my you know I guess there were younger
times you know previous years in my
comedy where I wanted to be like him
like man I wish I was more like him and
then now he oddly has helped me realize
a little bit like not you don't you want
to be like you you know like you you be
you do what you you know like like you
just like what you do is that's that's
that's what you do best so you don't
yeah you don't want to be like like I'm
you know I am me that's where I am it's
what I have to have to be me but you be
like you and uh and it's weird he's like
a general kind of he's at a bit of like
a like if he were an army dude he's the
[ __ ] general you know he's not the
[ __ ] I mean you know what else is he
gonna be he's not the dude who's
chopping wood like super early in the
morning he's the [ __ ] dude that's not
sleeping and that's being in the tent
probably grows a mustache you know
probably cuts off other people's legs
and [ __ ] just to [ __ ] try on their
shoes like you know he's a general but
yeah it would be cool
it could be cool man look anything's
possible that's what I'm learning in
this podcast universe and I'm just happy
I was so happy to have him as a guest
because I he's one of a kind dude I
don't know I've never seen anybody like
that man
I've never seen anybody like that man
let's take one more here from the from
the fan line that came in here we go
onward oh wait actually this video came
in through our regular website you can
submit videos as well if you don't have
the live race fan line app you can go to
theof on comm and in those ways to hit
the hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three there's also a ways
to submit a video on via Dropbox here we
go
what's up Theo my name is Casey I'm a
fan of the podcast thanks for checking
in with us Casey and if you look on
YouTube this man have a picture of a dog
in the back and this looks like um it
could be a Yorkie or something but I
don't even know what a Yorkie is dude
more I just wanted to send a video kind
of get your thoughts kind of bounce
something off of you
I'm a rollerblader and I've been doing
that for about almost 20 years I do team
pro Hey that's wild let's hear more
about tricks and stuff grind rails I'm
really good he's really good at what
roller I mean yeah it's good I mean
there's definitely I saw a dude [ __ ]
I saw a dude that went off this big
embankment one time on on rollerblades
and landed on some tram tracks on these
tram tracks in Atlanta and he had two
broken both of his legs I was probably
eighty yards away but you could almost
tell that both of his legs were broken
let's hear more though you sound like a
safer skater but it's one of the few
activities that people outwardly will
hate you for yeah yeah
I think that's true so I just wanted to
get your advice your thoughts what do
you do if you love doing something but
everybody else kind of hates it
that's a good question man what I do
look I'll say this you never know when
it's gonna come back in style right now
we might all have feet everybody's got
regular feet six years from now they're
[ __ ] hammering wheels into our feet
at birth so you may be ahead of the
curve man at that point you'd be 26
years ahead of the curve do you be the
Michelangelo of walking at that point
because you know wheeling would become
the new walking and you'd be taking us
everywhere so that you know you have
that so you might be ahead of the curve
you never know when you are ahead of the
curve man you know and also what about
this dude
I used to scrapbook I grew up
scrapbooking bruh you know I'm saying
you'll find me at Michael's son post it
up in the back cuz a Michaels great
place to meet bad [ __ ] all right and
to do scrapbooking and I did it for
years I got too much scrapbooks at the
house and bra I couldn't tell anybody
you know I couldn't tell anybody I was
freaking s bucking but now they have
dudes on Instagram with 3,400 posts
you know what Instagram is man
scrapbooking that's all it is
so I was ahead of the curve Giudice to
do it the old way you know I was Nelson
the mailman you know what I'm saying
I was out there putting in work and
doing things out there and a hundred
degree heat and Nelson's still getting
grandma's letter to you so maybe you
need to team up with Nelson and put some
wheels on that bad cat and next thing
you know you've revamped the whole mail
system because somebody I hope Elon Musk
comes along
I love the mail system and I've always
loved mail people and I've always been
fascinated by it I tried to mail myself
away I hate it growing up so much and
when I was a kid I remember going to the
post office in the middle of the night
and sitting in there and just hoping
that somebody would just mail me away
but I um I'll tell you this that
[ __ ] I forgot I [ __ ] forgot man damn
this episode is getting long all right
let's take another couple of calls man
what else do I want to tell you guys
about
I think this uh that's pretty much it we
got the dates coming up you can get
merch at the Obon calm slash store let's
take another call Casey oh this is
Morgan calling from Canada thanks for
calling Morgan I was just in your
country this Morgan
dude dude let me say this though
beautiful ladies up there beauty I mean
you'll see a beautiful lady working at
the airport you know you'll see a
beautiful lady like cleaning out even
the homeless people I saw a homeless
woman she was a [ __ ] 8 bruh
she don't heels like did him dirty Betty
out here flexing into my eyes bruh
dude unbelievable unbelievable brought
that glacier water you know I'm saying
that got them glacier wounds bruh and
when you got a cool pristine womb you
get that you get that beautiful bird
coming flying right out of that thing
let's hear more thanks for calling
Morgan I just had a question it's about
foot odor I was on a flight with my
girlfriend to go and meet her family in
England you know we have to share a row
of seats with this old lady
midway through the flight you mean a
senior citizen I'm guessing onward hey
not the old lady she decided to take her
slippers off it stunk up the whole cabin
it smells so bad that it almost made me
and my girlfriend have a fight you know
there's nothing you can say it's a nice
little old lady I don't want to insult
her this is maybe wondering if you can
give any advice well look man I suggest
this bra if you smell an old lady's feed
do some of this on you because you knew
if you know if Grammy Graham took her
shoes off you could put a little mask on
yourself or something you know or put a
little couple dollops of uh um you know
brown mustard under your nose so you
can't smell her feet cuz I think it's a
little bit pervy that you up there
smelling women's feet on a plane dude
you know and especially if your lady
your wife is sitting right there next to
on the plane and you sniffing old mom
mom's feet you sniffing them freaking 70
80 year-old hoofs that are hanging out
of her skirt cam and you're better than
that you're better than that dude dude
next time if I fall when it takes off
her shoes bro what I do is I take a
cross around my neck I kiss hit bruh and
I just hope the best for them and I'll
put a dollop a little bit of brown
mustard or something right up on other
daddies [ __ ] air hit her you know and
I shut it down because I ain't the type
of man gonna be smelling of senior
citizens you know uh you know metatarsal
things feet
sorry feet I'm not the type of person
gonna be smelling the senior citizens
feet and if their feet stink dude and
you get you a little bit of powder bra a
lot enough people don't carry powder
they got them little hitters of powder
full ounces of [ __ ] bit of powder you
know I'm saying well gran was asleep
they can't have any feeling in their
feet dude a 75 year old don't have any
feeling in their feet bruh their feet
are just these just you know just hot
things that have like blood in them and
and just you know and just toenails on
them they can't feel you [ __ ] just you
know you know that lady fell asleep
[ __ ] hit her with that you know just
dandruff them up with that freaking
beautiful dandruff that baby powder you
know what I'm saying with the [ __ ]
that's just Michelangelo's dandruff baby
that baby powder hit him with that [ __ ]
that John song is John song and next
thing you know she wakes up her feet
smell better
you and your lady aren't fighting
everything's healed you got to think
outside the bunions bruh yeah man take
another call that came in thank you for
that call though Morgan I appreciate it
and um and thank you for all my fans
from England dude I get so many people
to hit me up from England and I say fans
name I don't but I mean friends you know
all word hey this is Christina
I'm calling from Long Island New York I
what's up Christina from Long Island
that's cool I Love New York I love real
New Yorkers you know I'm saying people
that got that swagger
I like that swagger bruh oh we're
Christina thank you for calling had a
question um I know you're on I think a
low dosage of any de personnes and I was
wondering yes I am a moan um
fluoxetine and that's that generic
zoloft I think but I'm on something
generic I'm on maybe I think uh you know
kind of that second dose second range up
more what made you decide to start
taking them because I feel like I'm at a
point where you know I've tried diet and
exercise and I just like no matter what
I'm just I just keep going back to old
ways of feeling and my brain kind of
goes into overdrive and I'm not really
able to enjoy anything really and I'm 24
so I know like I'm young and people say
it's growing pains or whatever but I
just wanted your take on that because
I'm kind of considering taking them
because I just want to feel I just want
to feel okay well you know and I
appreciate that call and I'll take my
headphones off cuz sometimes I can think
a little bit more when I don't have them
on you know I man I just knew at the end
that you're gonna say I just want to
feel okay you know that's just what we
want to feel you know and it's so tough
it's so tough I feel II Christine or
Christina I'm sorry if I'm throwing in
an extra vowel or not throwing one in
but man that just when you do and you
feel like you're doing all you can and
there's just this there's this weight
for me it was this pain a little bit not
only would I feel bad but I had this
heaviness in the top of my lungs a
little bit that just felt like
something's wrong with me that I wasn't
okay it would almost be the feeling like
you're gonna get but if you were about
to cry a little bit but you didn't cry
it was just like this kind of it was
like this these cumulus clouds of of
Tears you know like a 40% chance of
[ __ ] feelings just sitting in my
lungs always um that would accompany me
not feeling well
and for me look uh yeah I'll tell you
when I got on them I got out of a
relationship I was 21 I think I was 21
and I was in Charleston South Carolina
and I hitchhiked up there to chase it
down a girl that broke up with me and
that I was in love with and the truth
was I mean I loved her you know but I
really loved her as a mother I looked at
her as a mother figure I didn't realize
it at the time even though there were
some clues when we when we broke up when
we broke up I say I remember her saying
you can't leave me I said you're like I
need you I said she's like you've never
acted like you needed me I said I need
you I said you're like a mother to me
that's what I said and just came out of
me I didn't realize that you know but
anyhow and I say that just to say that
obviously I had taken this relationship
and put extreme consequences and values
and pressures on it that weren't fair
for like you know too young you know
some Romeo and Juliet's you know like me
and this beautiful young lady this lady
was beautiful man she had this Native
American kind of look and I mean she
just had a heart that you know that
probably sunk to the bottom of the ocean
and people have been looking for forever
you know she had aa just a heart of gold
and and I um I just remember I remember
that that at that moment everything
inside of me whatever was broken inside
of me me not you know maybe not feeling
like I had affections of a mother or
whatever it is that it created me
feeling bad whatever made me feel less
than or made me feel depressed that
weighed inside of me that's when it
really started to take hold and I
remember going to a doctor and they just
come out with zoloft and dude I got on
it and through the and I felt great look
I could drink gin on it too I'll say
this I never even liked gin next thing
you know I'm wearing boat shoes and Buck
and watching sailing I'm drinking gin so
Zoloft and make you definitely you know
hang out by yeah I'm hanging out by a
yacht club you know
but since then I've been on it and
that's been you know 1314 years now that
I've been on and off of those drugs and
for the most time I've been on them and
it's hard to get off them and I'll say
this when I get off of them what I feel
like is how I felt before
I feel those feelings you know I feel
that feeling you cannot escape that I
can't be okay
and I worried for years especially when
I was your age I worried that man these
Kim I could feel the chemicals in my
brain sometimes a little bit you know if
I could feel myself feeling a little
okay even though [ __ ] was kind of weird
and then I was like well dang is this
okay I'm not I'm not really feeling my
real feelings you know I'm just kind of
masking things and and that's true I
think there's some truth to that because
your levels are a little higher and so
you know you know you're not feeling
those lows but I think if you still try
and focus on the work whatever work
needs to be done that solves those
problems and fixes those hurt feelings
then I think you can really lift
yourself up and maybe one day you can
get off of them and look or senior so
young that I mean in a few years they
could have some real natural holistic
ways and they do now there's a there's a
holistic medicine depression woman that
follows me on Instagram and she uh she's
constantly saying there ways to get off
of antidepressants and things like that
but if you think it could help you right
now I wouldn't feel ashamed about it you
know what pridefully i pridefully wake
up in the morning and take my low dose
zoloft or whatever it is and and I'm
just grateful you know and I have a lot
of good relationships in my life these
days and I don't have a lot of the same
low feelings that I used to have when I
was younger and I feel a little bit more
okay and a lot of that is because of you
know the medicine has been there was
like a training wheels for my feelings
along the way and and they're there for
me when I when I [ __ ] hit the lope
the low points you know and sometimes I
don't need them and so every now and
then I'll go like about five or six
months I'll wean myself off I'll talk to
my doctor and and I'll get out and I'll
get
off but then I usually get back on it's
kind of when you swim out in a pool when
you're young and you get a couple feet
from the wall and you start feeling
squirrelly
you know but you can still have fun in
the pool and those things just kind of
give you that wall you know but I would
I would feel okay with trying them and
that's my that's just a suggestion
but I would talk to a therapist or
psychologist first all right we got to
wrap it up man it's getting late and
Nick has to edit and we have to do some
other stuff we're gonna put out a video
here in the next do day or two we had
our first single mom come out in
Oklahoma Julie and we just haven't been
in town to edit thank you so much had a
great time in Canada I want to I want to
rock in this one more call right here
that came in here we go
this is a for the greatest weekend ever
every every weekend people can call in
and say what their weekend was like or
what their weekend wasn't like this past
weekend yeah here's the thing hit the
hotline nine eighty five six six four
nine five zero three let me know how you
if you had the best weekend of the worst
weekend don't call in with a shitty with
a nothing weekend I don't give a [ __ ] if
you were you know you looked out the
window and you saw somebody's cat you
know or you saw you know uh you know a
vulture or something
oh I don't give a [ __ ] bro you know why
because nobody gives a [ __ ] dude Colin
if you had a real weekend you know you
threw a javelin [ __ ] you know you
threw a javelin it landed in a you know
right in the middle of a watermelon
seventy yards away or you know something
happens somebody's in a fire somebody
want to contest somebody you know got a
crown you know you found a bag of molars
in your front yard you know call them
with a real story something that
happened and we have two people that are
entering that contest for this month
every month will will give out a prize
pack to whoever calls in with the best
or the worst weekend we only choose one
here are two submissions that have just
come in here we go hey Co my name is
Maci I'm from Texas so this past weekend
I flew to Alabama to see my boyfriend
that was sweet of you you know the girl
that I've fallen for that I got out fell
out of love with and got on
antidepressants
she went to University of Alabama onward
southern love you know I'm saying dang
gay I'm gonna fight back to Texas I was
sitting there thinking about how I
wanted to leave my job for past two
months but it's hard because I worked
there for 60 years and so I get home and
I'm thinking like then I put in my two
weeks then I put in my two weeks and I'm
sitting there watching your podcast and
you start talking about how we need to
grow and there's too much opportunity to
stay stagnant and you got to start with
taking one step at a time
yeah I mean look and I say those things
and I'm not preaching I'm definitely
reminding myself onward so I paused the
podcast and I walked into my boss's
office and put in my two weeks and I
want to see never felt better so just
want to say thank you for for those
words of wisdom Wow that's brave you put
in that two weeks notice I'm sure your
boss is like well now you're listening
to podcasts on the job so he probably
may who knows if he'd been meaning to
ask you to leave for a while I just I
just I know a lot of people listen to
podcast as a passive listening and uh
but good for you you know it's brave
dude change his brave changes where
things happen you know people you know
say they hate America these days they
hate this in that and it's hectic it's
hectic because people are alive but man
is [ __ ] anything can happen now
anything else bozo you know it may be
something bad it may be something good
but I think anything can happen and not
only that that feeling only arise arises
when there's change you know when
something different when something
shakes up the [ __ ] norm you know I
want to make a few changes in my life
right now and I'm afraid you know I've
been pushing them off for with this and
that and this and that and you know not
sure and not knowing what my instincts
are and and what's my ego and just and
it's hard but a lot of times you could
check and you can go back but man and
get out there and take that first step
mMmmm that sounds like a good weekend to
me thank you for calling about that Macy
let's go one more here here we go hey
this is Chris Collins from Birmingham
Alabama oh that's crazy she was just uh
well [ __ ] this could be Chris her
boyfriend
but like you I was bored or raised in
that book baby oh he's down in the boot
that's what he's talking about Louisiana
thank you for calling Chris and for
those who don't know what the boot is
that's the greatest state in this union
Louisiana is definitely one of the top
50 states you know great place to get a
boisterous great place to get dementia
bruh you know what I'm saying
onward but anyway I got up that's the
weekend for you I was watching the US
Open and they had a segment about a past
winner named Raymond Floyd but that's
not the important part the important
part is in the background of that
segment
they had that hitter and I'm talking
about shine but Bishop was playing in
the background the first time I heard
that song was on your podcast baby so I
just wanted to let you know how ahead of
the curve you are keep up the good work
with the podcast hey come and perform at
the Alabama Theatre in Birmingham
Alabama I'll be there with bells on I
see oh you keep doing what you're doing
dang he'll be there with bells on dude
and you know I grew up I used to live by
a Jingle Bell factory and I used to
balance him on my chest at night so we
can get molested or attacked so I would
hear I'm like a little bit of an alarm
system but you know what's so funny man
that yeah that Bishop gun you know
they're doing nice things and and and
the drummer I said it before I used to
work on his father's farm the drummer of
that band his father employed me out of
college to work on their farm and I got
to know the family and and my buddy who
hired me passed ways and you know he he
was many beautiful things he suffered
from some addiction and I'm not throwing
him under the bus but I you know I know
that he would he would one other young
people or young men that struggle to
know that that's a real thing that can
happen but it's I feel so blessed to
know his son who's the drummer of that
band and and somebody hit me up on
Twitter and said man I was just watching
the US Open and I heard Bishop Gunn on
the way out of that thing so right here
let's close out today man thank you so
much we had some other great calls we'll
have to put them on on
next time man Thank You Calgary I'll see
you guys in Bakersfield this week we got
those other those other places just go
get them
you guys be good to yourself because you
probably deserve it man I'm ready to
hear this hitter hi CI this is a burning
ban of Nexus Mississippi would play for
Bishop building we're in that Bishop
burn ban oh yeah a surprise
confrontation over here anyway look
we're talking about the dark arts
decision we're sitting in the living
room and we're just wondering is the
bush making it come back here come in
oh you mean George Bush for the record
when that time with the presidency we're
talking about vaginas yeah oh okay you
talking about that that you don't say
talking about that pheasant boy
hairstyles revolving around that I just
don't see much of the whole industry up
or the triangle much more seasoned it's
either all gone or it's all there is you
I'm saying are you talking about that
full feel that you talking about that
you know that front 40 well it's funny
you talk about that you know like it's
so funny because his this is the drummer
right now that called and a bishop gun
of the band and they're asking is that
but you know is that thing making a
comeback or what is it yeah I don't know
you know I don't mind I don't want that
cornfield down there I'll use terms
since I used to work on his father's
farm I don't want them you know I don't
want them stalks you know I don't want
that field of dreams down there but I
will you came even you know saying you
might lose if you bring a friend you
might lose them down there or you might
lose your freakin you know a piece of
jewelry I don't want that you know but I
wouldn't mind something a little
low-grade you know maybe some soybean
you know maybe something as high as corn
but you know me not corn with cotton
maybe some Milo you know wheat I'll go
with that Streamy wheat down there bruh
you know a little bit of cream of wheat
you know get a serving going I'll do
something like that but I don't know is
the bush making a comeback how's it
going that's a good asset tough question
maybe some ladies if there's some ladies
out there who listen can you let us know
is that Bush gonna make a comeback you
know I was just talking to a black
friend of mine about the jheri curl hair
cut where the [ __ ] is that thing you
know a lot of men out there a lot of uh
a lot of a lot of african-american and
black men out there saying they got that
swagger they braved they this stayed
that but ain't nobody ready to rock that
J curl out there where's that at you
know I'm saying Gries up and grease out
baby let's see it all because y'all want
to see that hang time coming off the
back you ain't got the balls to grow the
falls baby and you know that so let's
see it man I wouldn't mind seeing that I
would let's see it all let's see it all
man and we'll put the link to this song
in the in the footnotes on the way out
and this is shine by Bishop gun man
you're gonna love this band you're gonna
love the rest of the music as well let's
get that head
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far from my
home and my mind is somewhere else but
when I found it our patch up where it's
been grown blown not grown now just
float on the breeze but not feel full
and like these leaves that must be
cornerstone I'm gonna bring up reduce oh
great into the sky isn't that enough
thought it's gonna take
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself shine
this Nick Davis man the best producer
ever just so great I got chef that
Bishop gone thank you for uh for being
here but this past weekend yeah we got
some great guests coming up here and
we're uh well nothing I said enough you
guys be good new sales I bet you deserve
[Music]
makes him some word I came
I'll tell you